eleven thousand years if that event
happened today to us our civilization is
gone if we survive it we will be knocked
back to hunter-gatherers and in a
generation or two we'll be sitting
around the campfire telling ghost
stories about plasma TVs and dancing
around with black shiny rocks trying to
turn it on and say well this thing will
give you answer to anything and you can
talk to someone the other you know it's
magic can you paint that picture a
little bit like if Young address happens
today if you're anywhere near the actual
impact site or the errors I mean you're
just gone every building instantly
disintegrated the entire planet well if
it's big enough I mean that's the
problem is that you go back far enough
in these these Extinction events I mean
some of them have eliminated like 99.9
of Earth if that happens it's game over